good morning billion nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my WOD word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all the world's major
problems I started to believe life
series to try to expand beyond just the
world of entrepreneurship and try to
learn some other skills resources ideas
to help us become maybe a more complete
human being so today we're going to
learn some hiking tips for beginner and
as always guys if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the count's below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy
[Music]
you ever wonder what separates those
living in alley life from those who live
a mediocre one you think it's their bank
account guess again
it makes time for adventure make time
for adventure
don't get me wrong there's many things
that separate in alley life from a
mediocre one but today I want to talk
about memories and experiences I mean
these are things that we all have right
but at what level and what frequency
ultimately guys life in my opinion is
and should be an adventure over the past
year and a half I've studied countless
world-class leaders is something that
I've noticed they all have in common
that they constantly create memorable
experiences in 2015 I made it a point to
make time for adventure and during the
summer of 2015
I probably fit in more adventures than I
probably put in my entire life that was
life-changing
[Music]
- they never found the time spirit until
I changed on my I ultimately decided to
make time and I planned a new place to
explore every week I planned my life
work around some trips with ji some half
days summer weekends some were four days
one game and I wants to go to work I've
always found time whether it be along
the short venture and I've honestly
my happier to my life I mean really
what's the point of doing anything
you're not having fun doesn't elevate
you emotionally I know we all have
things that we must do day to day that
may not be fun it can get a bit bland so
why not make time to take on any
adventure a half-day or weekend every
week every month this will snap you out
of any complacency you may be feeling
don't let yourself be completion
complacency it's the killer of dreams
and ambition you can start right now by
making a list of adventures that you
want to take throughout the rest of the
year
hi my name is John and today we're going
to do a little beginners intro to hiking
and one of the things that I love about
hiking is is that it truly is very very
simple you put one foot in front of the
other
you get out into a beautiful natural
area like this and that is the essence
of hiking of course there are a few tips
and suggestions that will make the
beginners experience a little bit easier
and will avoid some of the common
pitfalls that people without experience
come across when they go outside first
things first I always like to talk about
the feet make sure that you have
appropriate Footwear on these boots that
I'm wearing today are more of my heavier
duty hiking boots it is also appropriate
if you're going on easier terrain to use
running shoes or lightweight hiking
shoes even Tevas or other hiking style
sandals can be adequate if you know what
you're doing in the terrain is more
forgiving for dress I always like to
address particularly lightly shorts
lightweight long pants a t-shirt and
maybe a jacket if it's a cooler day that
you might store in your pack if you
start on it's warmer but it might be
raining later on as far as carrying some
things with you some very essential or
basic things a day pack is really good
for your shorter hiking trips internet
day pack or carrying with you end up
water please bring plenty of water if
you're going to go for an hour to one
water bottle sufficient multiple hour
hikes would take multiple water bottles
so a little bit of food some snacks good
old raisins and peanuts aka Gorp
something just an extra jacket always be
prepared even if there's no rain in the
forecast it might rain on you I always
bring an extra jacket like that
first-aid kit sunblock those are pretty
much the essentials now as far as
planning a place to go hiking almost
anybody in this country lives near a
beautiful park or a wild Natural Area
today we're in Montana de Oro State Park
here in California as you can see
thousands of acres wonderful hiking
trails here if you're beginning I would
pick out a trail that might be two or
three miles in length maybe a little bit
shorter pretty moderate terrain as you
get used to it you can work up and do
heavier duty trails with more up and
down terrain eight or ten miles
with a lot of up-and-down would be a
really full hiking day for folks that's
hiking in a nutshell and I hope that
that helps beginners get a feel for it
and avoid some of the common problems
that happen to folks who don't really
know what they're doing out there well
the hiking have a plan
99% of the time that I travel in the
backcountry I do so alone something I
just really enjoy so it's really
important on the front end of my trips
that I have a plan and so what I do is I
do some research online look at websites
at the area I'm going to be in a look at
a map to see where I'm going to park my
truck I look at the various destinations
I want to get to how long how many miles
it's going to take for me to get there
how long it's going to take to hike
those miles another thing I look at is
weather so that I can anticipate if
there's going to be any precipitation
rain or snow and I know the high
particular dicted high temperatures and
the low temperature so I can pack
accordingly I always carry a compass and
a map when I'm traveling in the
backcountry what I do is I take the
National Geographic trails Illustrated
map it's a big color map and I'll take
photocopies of the sections or the areas
that I'm going to be hiking in and I put
those in a gallon ziplock bag it allows
me to travel lighter it protects those
documents I can write on the maps and
not damage the original map and it's
very lightweight for me to travel in the
backcountry that way and also I carry my
iPhone which has a GPS built into it
with a topo app and I just run the phone
in airplane mode and so it conserves
battery power and I pull that out every
once in a while if I want to double
check where I'm at but primarily I use
my map and compass I leave a detailed
itinerary with at least two people one
is always my wife I told exactly we're
going to park my pickup and what my plan
is for while I'm in the backcountry
where I'm going to be and so on and the
other person I'll leave this information
with is a good friend of mine who knows
the area and has the ability to come get
me if I run into trouble most of time
when you read about someone who's
experienced a tragedy in the backcountry
while traveling solo it's because they
didn't tell anybody
where they went day hikes so this video
this portion of the video is going to be
for day hikes that are you know 1 to 3
miles I'm going on a day hike that's 1 2
or 3 miles these are the items that I'm
going to break first thing I focus on
food and water what I have here today
it's perfect for 1 to 3 miles sometimes
I bring a little more I just have some
granola and some peanuts simple snack to
snack on
sometimes I'll bring some extra granola
bars sometimes even a can of soup
depending on the area that I'm going so
that's food water usually I'll just
bring one canteen and if I'm going for
longer distances usually I bring a
bladder pack or if I know the area that
I'm going in I'll bring a water filter
this way I can fill up my canteen when I
stop their stream or something like that
so that's food and water covered for you
know one to three mile hike protection
from the elements usually I'll just
bring a poncho and this will basically
keep me dry in all my gear that I have
dry a cheap alternative would be a big
trash bag so you can get them fairly
cheap just cut a hole on the top and for
your arms and there you go you got your
own poncho very lightweight and cheap I
would recommend not buying the dollar
soul ponchos because they tear very
easily if you're going in the area where
it's you know a small footpath and you
scrape up against your branch chances
are here the poncho is going to tear if
you buy the cheap quality one so I'd
recommend maybe getting one that's a
little more higher quality than the
dollar store brand so that's protection
from the elements for the one two three
day height want to pre mile hike what I
like to call just encase items so again
fire-starting if for some reason you do
get lost very simple wearing a lighter
bring two lighters bring three lighters
keep them in different locations because
if for some reason you lose your
backpack you know I mean all your fire
stuff is in the backpack what are you
going to do so keep a lighter in your
pocket maybe keep a letter in your
jacket I have another one in my inside
pocket here and keep a couple in your
backpack you know practice using a Ferro
rod of course
but that's the basics of fire keep
something to light a fire on you and a
letter to me in my opinion is the best
way another thing just in case item
bring some flashlights I have this cheap
headlamp here this actually cost ten
dollars it's rechargeable I did a test
the battery I kept it on the highest
setting it lasts for about 11 hours and
still didn't die so I just shut it off
at that point like you know determined
is very very useful 10 dollars on Amazon
if I can remember where I got it from of
the name I'll put it in the description
for you guys so bring some type of light
I have another light on my keychain here
it's a very small light but it's very
effective it's a high powered LED light
I'd recommend bringing multiple lights
if you can small flashlights work fine
you know you don't need anything
high-tech or expensive and I actually
keep another headlamp in my pocket here
just in case I get stay with me at all
times in my jacket just in case this is
my my better headlamp that I purchased
so just in case you do get lost and
you're out longer than expected and it
does become night you want to have light
to be able to navigate
and that's basically it for day hikes
something I usually bring to just this
little foam pad just for comfort you
know if I stop to sit down for a second
put it on my bum sit down infection cozy
so my buttons are numb numb so that's
something simple there and I also use
this to fan the fire sometimes so just
some comfortable items that I bring and
that's the basics for you know one two
three mile hike it's not too extensive
you don't need a lot when you're going
out hiking just focus on the area that
you're in know the area that you're in
and know how to get out just in case for
longer hikes I would bring all this
stuff that I just explained I will also
bring a water filter very important and
I would also bring this my laptop and
it's great for protection from the
elements if I had to make an emergency
shelter I could put this up in a lean-to
fashion have a fire in front of me and
it should keep me warm the entire night
I've actually done it before I highly
recommend these my laptop's I believe it
was like $15 on Amazon lightweight very
very versatile item and they come in a
couple different colors but this is my
favorite piece of kit that I have and I
highly recommend it I bought one I liked
it so much about two more so it says a
lot if you're just getting into hiking I
recommend bring more than you need you
know if you can bear the weight on your
back bring more than you need and then
over time you'll get used to the gear
that you don't need and little by little
you'll have less and less and less
that's basically how I decided on what
gear I should bring I win you know my
pack was a little heavy in the beginning
but over time I was like God never even
use this on the last three hike so I'm
going to take it out of my bag and then
you just go for go on from there so
that's it you get a nice comfortable
backpack you know over time obviously
you don't want to spend a hundred
dollars on a backpack if you're going
out hiking for the first time you know
get something cheap and just learn and
grow and get out there and experience
the woods and tell me about your
adventure respect the backcountry what I
mean by this is that when I am in the
back edge of travel alone whether I'm
scaling a steep slope to get a peak or
I'm crossing
a stream I keep a slogan in the back of
my mind and that is remember where you
are and what that reminds me is that if
I were to get hurt
right at that moment I am days away
potentially from anyone coming to help
me so it helps me to be vigilant when
I'm hiking down the trail or stepping
from Boulder to Boulder most times when
people have accidents in the backcountry
is due to laziness or not you're just
not paying attention I mean I get it you
get fatigued it's late in the day and
you're just not paying attention when
you're putting your full weight down on
a rock you just assume that rock is
stable and you can't when you're
traveling alone you get an injury by
yourself and there's nobody there to
help you so remembering where you are
just helps you to be vigilant at all
times so that you minimize your risk and
then last on the list is emergency
shelter we call them a bibbing and
here's a two-person bivy and a small
container and here's a one-person booby
you can see how small these are you
throw it in your pack and if you never
need it you never know it's there but
when you do need it
it'll save your life so definitely
recommend that one of the things I like
to carry on some big trips in the North
Cascades is my spot to messenger I can
check in with my wife and kids let them
know that I'm okay and if I do need help
I can hit the button it works with
satellite and it works very well it's
been out for a long time
I also recommend that you maybe bring a
plastic bag this is great for shelter as
well as keeping everything dry if you're
an interracial downpour you get wet you
get cold you're in trouble things to
think about is weight if you go on a
trip you obviously got to keep your
weight in proportion to what you can
carry
so scale down or scale up things
depending on where you're going use
common sense are you taking a long trip
are there hazards is there going to be
weather problems you know be able to
deal with everything nobody wants to
call search-and-rescue and nobody wants
to find themselves spending an unwanted
night in the wilderness what are the
main categories or classes of hiking
boots there's four main styles and
categories of hiking boots the first
would be the low cut ultralight hiking
boots and then it would be just a
general all-purpose hiker and then
indigo with a little bit heavier in a
backpacking hiking boot and then the
heaviest and most durable would be the
mountaineering and winter hiking boots
the ultralight hiking boots are designed
for the backpacker who wants to cut down
on their weight on their trips most of
them are not waterproof they're mostly
lightweight breathable but they provide
for easier comfort through the day
they're going to keep your feet dry even
if you go through water they're going to
breathe a lot faster so you are going to
dry out quicker moeslem do you have a
pretty aggressive tread to kind of keep
going through most of the rugged terrain
in Idaho a lot of customers are a lot of
people who are going out hiking prefer
to not have ankle ankle support a lot of
people do people with ankle injuries
especially don't like to have the
high-top boots because it rubs on scars
or scar tissue and so we get a lot of
people asking them for a lower cut still
aggressive and still rugged shoe now
I've heard that one pound on your feet
actually equals five pounds on your back
is that true yeah absolutely
it's your feet are moving all day and if
you think about lugging one of these
around as opposed to one of these I mean
it's it's way different this is three
pounds of foot this is 16 ounce not even
16 ounces would be like 12 ounces of
foot
and so you're cutting a lot of weight
and they're moving all day and so at the
end of the day you're going to have a
lot more energy wearing these out than
you are when you wear these heavier
heavier duty mountaineering boots Sam
more of a heavyweight backpacker I go on
a lot rougher terrain I'm carrying
weights you know 30 40 maybe 50 pounds
or more what type of bridge am I going
to Silicon in that situation we're in
that situation and a step up to kind of
a all-around back packing boot most of
them are all leather so you're going to
get a lot of waterproofing you can use a
Nick wax or something like that to also
waterproof them as well and then most of
them have Vibram soles and so they're
going to provide a little bit more
traction and a little more stability and
then it's a lot wider of a base than a
traditional hiking shoe and so it's
going to provide that stability kind of
lesson right one of the main things to
kind of keep in mind which a lot of
people don't know is trying on boots
later on during the day your feet tend
to swell as you're standing around and
walking around so knowing that you're
going to your feet are going to be a
little bit different even a half-size
different later in the day is going to
help when you tire at the end of a hike
so trying on shoes later in the day
definitely helps because you're going to
it's more of a true fit is there
anything else I can do in store to make
sure that the boot is going to work and
I know some stores offer maybe incline
ramps or other devices can you maybe
speak to that just quickly absolutely an
incline ramp is crucial and trying out a
boot you definitely want to lace your
boot up like you're going to wear it and
then start at the top and kind of
stutter step your way down and make sure
that your toes aren't hitting the front
because if they're hitting the front 4
or 5 steps down the incline ramp they're
going to hit on the way down from a
mountain and then you turn around and
walk back up and make sure that your
heel isn't slipping in the back because
that would cause a blister pretty
quickly so once I've actually tested the
shoes picked them out purchased them
what do I need to do prior to hitting
the telethons I just break them out of
the box and go for a hike or whatever
prior to taking them out on your first
trip or your first adventure would be
just wearing them around the house for a
short amount of time a lot of these the
stiffer ones are going to take a long
time to break in some people would Pat
them on for two three years and still
haven't broken them in so definitely
taking them on like short walks around
the block if you've got a dog and you're
walking a dog or even taking them on
little mini hikes that way you're
breaking them in but you're still you're
not committed to them when you're out
there and you don't have anything else
to change into
you only need a handful of gums to stay
warm dry and comfortable in rain wind or
snow so that you can enjoy views like
this hi I'm Jonathan Simons and I'm a
wildlife tracker bushcraft instructor
and in my spare time a keen bird watcher
and Hill Walker so I spend a lot of my
time outdoors every time I do go out I
use the same versatile clothing system
known as the layering system to keep me
warm dry and comfortable and today I'm
going to show you how it works
I'm working with my friends that go
outdoors who have all the know-how on
outdoor kit at their fingertips so light
and packable clothing that forms a
layering system is designed to be kept
in your rucksack so they can be pulled
out at a moment's notice to see how it
works we need to rewind to the start of
the day the first part of the layering
system is the base layer it's designed
to trap a thin layer of warm air against
my body and pulls all wicks sweat vapor
away from the skin it also keeps me very
warm and dry I'm wearing a base layer
made of merino wool
it's fibers are so fine it doesn't itch
or scratch Maryna also helps neutralize
body odor and it's an environmentally
friendly renewable fabric there's one
base layer fabric that you need to avoid
and that's cotton cotton soaks up sweat
like a sponge and this is bad news
because when cotton gets wet it draws
heat away from your body and this can
lead to hypothermia
hypothermia is a potentially lethal
condition and can be contracted in
surprisingly mild weather so unless
you're in a hot climate avoid wearing
cotton clothing and of course avoid
wearing cotton underwear and socks -
well if getting to or so it's time to
throw on the next part of my layering
system which is the mid layer now the
mid layer is designed to trap body heat
and to allow sweat paper to carry on
moving through the layering system the
most popular mid layer fabric is fleece
as it's affordable durable and quick
drying the thicker the fleece the War
heated traps
so you want to mid weight fleece for
colder weather and a thin or micro
fleece like this one from milder
conditions as you gain altitude the
temperature drops so remember on the
summit it could be quite cold in though
is really warm down in the car park but
ambient temperatures are part of the
story
wind and rain can have a big impact on
just how cold and uncomfortable it can
feel which is where the next part of the
layering system comes in this outer
layer known as the shell blocks wind and
rain it also allows my sweat paper to
leave the layering system now I'm
wearing a waterproof para no shell
actually very comfortable indeed
sadly there are three types of shell
paramos membrane and coated nylon they
all do a great job in keeping out the
element that they vary in how quickly
their last sweat vapor to move from the
inside to the outside of the garment
paramos MIT quacks analogy fabric which
is what John is wearing and membranes
are the two types of waterproof and
breathable materials that are best
suited for active youth para moat is
very breathable and great and keeping
you comfortable in many weather
conditions but the material is heavier
than some membranes and coated nylon
membranes such as gore-tex event and dew
point are lighter and more packable than
para MO but they don't breathe quite as
effectively the third type of outer
layer is a coated nylon these shells are
designs passive activities such as
walking the dog short ramble to the de
sac or hiking to the pub coated nylons
are less expensive and less breathable
than para mo or membranes and will feel
sweaty during arduous activities you can
use the layering system on your legs too
you can layer a pair of merino or
synthetic leggings underneath your wind
resistance somewhere tracking trousers
and you can pull on a pair of breathable
and waterproof over trousers should the
weather come in an alternative to the
leg wear layering system is a pair of
softshell trousers like these soft show
is a popular leg wear material as if
time-consuming to adjust multiple layers
on the move hi there guys I'm out here
enjoying nature again just next to a
nice little village on the Alps and
because the moor is out and about doing
all sorts of adventures a few people are
asking me about hiking like what sort of
gear do you take when you go hiking over
night camping and so on or what do you
need what do you actually take when you
go so here are selected 15 items that I
consider the basic kids things they
should be taking if you go on that sort
of activity so let's get started with
number one is your tent like this maybe
four one two three or more people
maybe 3 season 4 season it all depends
on what sort of conditions you're going
to be facing number two is some sort of
isolating met by the main function of
this is not only to give you some
comfort against the hard ground
underneath your sleeping bag but also to
protect you from cold and humidity
coming from the ground talking about
cold
number three is your sleeping bag make
sure that the temperature rating of your
sleeping bag is adequate to the
temperatures that you're going to be
facing consider that at nighttime the
temperature can drop quite a lot number
four is your kitchen so it's a kitchen
kiss really so here is your stove
several models out there gas alcohol
multi fuel and so on your pot and eating
it ain't just number five it's one of my
favorites is your food package breakfast
lunch dinner trails next and so on I'm
going to be talking about all this gear
on another video giving more details and
being a specific phobia that was number
five number six is water bottles not
only to keep your hydrating during the
walk and during the camping but also you
know to measure water for cooking and a
lot of them can be used with water
purification system which is our next
item number seven now this could be a
filter you can use water purification
tablet maybe even boil water but it's
quite important to treat water you don't
want to get contaminated especially when
you can pee on remote areas number
weight is a torch I personally like
headlamps and three walking a night
cooking after dark and so on very handy
make sure it takes very batteries number
nine is a first-aid kit with a
multi-tool or a knife I make sure that
this is always on a waterproof bag I do
the same with the rest of my gear but
particularly with this one
number ten is your personal hygiene kit
so this is where your toothpaste
toothbrush is you might want to take a
small microfiber towel and your toilet
paper also kept in a small dry bag
number eleven is your clothing
it's a package of fresh dry warm layers
for the temperature dropped you want to
make sure you're warm and protected and
it is talking about protection we go to
number 12 which is rain jacket in rain
tank here when we outdoors we are always
exposed rain winter wind snow and so on
you want to make sure you dry and warm
they also give you a lot of protection
against the wind the next item is a mat
covering the entire area encompassed and
ideally some basic orienteering skills
as well that well number 14 is a small
pouch with your wallet phone and keys
and so on here you can also keep copies
of reservations like an entry for
national park for some sort of ticket
for transportation and so on I am lately
Leslie our left item number 15 a
backpack of the something appropriate
for hiking it must be comfortable and
with capacity big enough for all your
gear and maybe a little bit more so that
you don't have to pack everything
extremely precise you've got a little
bit of margin to play around with right
so there is a pretty much as 15 basic
items that I consider is the basic kit
for hiking staying overnight
thank you guys to what you're watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video what was the
message that you took home that you're
going to immediately apply somehow in
your life or maybe in your business
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick chatter to Edward Edward
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book dear one word I hope you
enjoyed the read man and I'm so
appreciative for you
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love have an amazing
day
we'll see you soon